every mask every second house has an
access to Tunnel so this is and and of
course imun that's an argument for
destroying the whole of
Gaza Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you will in be reaping the reward click
the link and donate what you
Canam brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshah
I'm here with Muhammed hijab and SM to
jna what we're going to react to brother
sisters is David Cameron so why is David
Cameron being appointed with Zan what is
he he's the he's I think he's the
foreign secretary of the United Kingdom
so he's supposed to um be talking about
issues pertaining you know Foreign
Relations he's supposed to be diplomatic
and most importantly he's supposed to be
honest CU if you're honest that's when
you get Solutions so you can't be you
know beating around the bullsh
especially if there's a genocide you
know just that's oxim with the
politician is it it's it's like a um a
virgin prostitute I don't know I don't
know oh okay yeah yeah I mean expecting
honesty from U these individuals
escalated very quickly did but that's
the reality but so we're going to watch
a video in this video he's asked some
questions some very basic questions
about the disgusting vile Ambassador who
is calling for an ethnic cleansing
absolute outright genocide uh we're
going to watch that video and then the
um the reply of David Cameron and see
what the brothery have to say for that
what assessment have you made of the
israelian ambassador's claim she said
that in the television every mask every
second house has an access to Tunnel so
this is and and of course IM mun that's
an argument for destroying the whole of
Gaza do you have another solution so in
your opinion was she freelancing when
she was speaking to that television
interviewer or was she speaking for the
Israeli government I I don't know I
would hope that that that is not the
position of the Israeli government cuz
it's the wrong position I mean you heard
that for yourself guys um you heard what
she said on I think it was LBC was lb we
see it was okay good so she's basically
clearly firstly there is no evidence
every house every mosque every second
house every has a tunnel you cann't find
one tunnel in in one hospital let alone
there's tunnels everywhere and then
she's being asked she's saying basically
what else do you want us to do in nutsh
show basically we have to it's a
massacre yeah an absolute ethnic
cleansing and David Cameron's asked this
and he is being asked is this coming
from herself so there's an ambassador
can they speak of their self or if she's
an ambassador to Israel she's outright
speaking on their behalf any realm in
any respect so you've never had a piece
of paper in front of you by a foreign
office lawyer that says that Israel is
in breach of its International
humanitarian commitments under
International humanitarian law um look I
I I the reason for to answer this
question I can't recall every single bit
of paper that's been put in front of me
I see I look at everything I mean of
course there are lots of things that
have happened where you think well
surely that is that was something that
shouldn't have happened and and so I
don't want to answer that question
because for me in 2013 you were quite
happy to say from the dispatch box that
war crimes have been committed by the
Assad regime when it came to chemical
weapons use and two years later you were
happy to say that Hamas had committed a
war crime when they shot Rockets into
Israel and you saw his reaction what did
you guys make out of it well first and
foremost David Cameron has said some
things in the past which have been
positive to the Palestine cause of
course he said some negative things and
he's a bit of a mixed bag when it comes
to these things in the past he's been
quoted as saying that Gaza is an open
prison something which Norman finlin
references actually quite often in in
his um speeches and also in his books
David Cameron was one of the first
people to actually mentioned that Gaza
is an open prison however they're very
careful not to to designate anything
legally you you probably noticed this so
for example I don't think he has yet to
state for example that Israel is
committing war crimes or that he's not
stated and he knows this cuz he was the
Prime Minister of this country that uh
that they're doing Collective punishment
I mean in international law the
threshold for for genocide is much
higher than for example for Collective
punishment or war crimes but he hasn't
even gone for the for the lower
threshold designation which is in this
case just war crimes and Collective
punishment he has come recently and
spoken about or actually proposed that
anyone who's building illegal
settlements from uh in in the West Bank
in Israel Israeli person in the West
Bank doing illegal settlements will not
be allowed in the UK which was met with
some level of congratulation if you like
from the Muslim Community and other Pro
Palestine activists as well as I would
say a large TR of the British population
um what I see here in terms of what what
David Cameron's doing effectively
because he's a very smart man he's had a
long career as a politician is he's once
again giving an honest opinion that's
the imputation here he's not effectively
making a legal designation because he
knows the implication of that it will
harm diplomatic relationships between
him and who he sees as as an ally in
Israel it will harm even diplomatic
relationship between him and the United
States of America he's very aware of
that connection because America hasn't
given these guys the green light to
start making designations of a
international legal kind but I think
there's something in him which sees the
abhorrence of what's going on in
Palestine and he's in a effect
stretching his capabilities in being
able to as I mentioned uh designate some
kind of honest opinion on the matter
without going too deeply into the
legalities that's what I think is
happening interesting
you yeah I I I wouldn't give him too
much credit to be honest I mean someone
in his position um unless you're just um
neutral you you're just there you're
you're gray you're just there to just be
a part of the system not to really bring
about anything of meaningful change then
he's he's pretty much doing the right
thing but when we're actually looking at
what they're in effect trying to do
which is um that the cause for genocide
is just ridiculous it's a quote after
quote after quote um which is just
compounding and these are people that
are making decisions you've got the
foreign was it the um you got the UK
Ambassador you've got the Israel Finance
Minister you've got the Israeli Heritage
Minister saying abor things calling for
literally the wiping out of all of Gaza
and all of gazans
so for this guy to come out when over
20,000 people have been killed 30,000 by
the way now 30 now 30,000 and 12,000 of
them are kids yeah 12,000 of them are
kids for the for him to come along when
you have an Israeli ambassador to the UK
100,000 signatures have come in on that
petition and 100,000 people last time I
checked want that witch to be put back
on her broom and sent back she like a
here I would like to call her something
else that starts with a b b but I'll
refrain from doing so cuz I believe that
has more um yeah but but that's that's
the way she's you know let's let's send
her back frankly because she's not
helping the cause exactly yeah at the
very least like if you look at Tel Aviv
now people have flooded the streets
because they are unhappy with what their
leader is doing but then you've got this
foreign secretary who can't even bring
words to his lips that everybody
everybody knows I mean my question would
be what's Epstein got on him that would
be my question on him because Epstein's
list seems to be growing and growing you
even got Steven Hawking you know all of
these memes of of of him and was it even
Richard Dawkins you've got all sorts of
people going to his Island and the
disc the connections with I mean Jalan
Maxwell the daughter of a mosad agent I
mean it's ex mosad agent on RT News
admitting that yes you know he was an
asset to mosad so I mean there's things
more Insidious going on but what he now
doing is he is harming he's creating
more harm than he is benefit because
politicians are already being seen as
useless anyway I mean UK and us they're
not being taken seriously because they
are blindly siding with Israel now when
he comes along he's supposed to be
bringing another flavor and he's not
able to do that he can't bring it to his
lips the woman said this she said what
other solution do you have and he's
saying uh is it this or is it from her
opinion who gives a monkeys this is that
ised to be ambassador to the UK that's I
mean look at the role what use is her
opinion on an LBC interview they're not
asking her opinion they're asking what
her country is going to do about the
genocide taking place yes you're
justifying it you know in in a nutshell
and to be honest it reminds me of you
know Hitler's Nazi Germany the final
solution she's in a nutshell saying that
in different ways I mean she's basically
saying what else should we do that's an
argument for destroying the whole of
Gaza do you have another solution oh I
mean is to me it's like calling for a
final solution you can see and it's very
ironic coming from a Jewish Heritage uh
you know which they are Zionist for that
matter and that's it there's nothing
else to be said alhamdulillah they put
it beautifully from sisters there's
going to be the petition Link at the
bottom in in we can Deport this woman
back to where she came from till next
time the prophet sallu alhi wasallam
said whoever builds a Masid for the sake
of Allah subhana tala Allah will build
for him a similar house in jenah on that
day where Allah subhana tala tells us
that our books will be given and every
little atom weight of Good Deed you've
done will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you allowed people to pray you
built a Masjid I never had the money to
build a Masid oh Allah you helped you
gave towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you've built it donate
now guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra Rewards
oh